Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and recently
an interview with Kristian Nairn who plays
Hodor has everyone thinking Bran Stark’s
story isn’t going to be featured in Season
5.
At all.
I’ll explain what was said in the interview
and what he did not say.
It’s a game of telephone where people are
repeating what other people interpret.
The original interview says almost nothing
about season 5.
It’s just this one bit, and HBO has thus
far refused to comment.
So let’s start with the actual interview.
The part that caused everyone to crap their
pants went like this, Nairn said and this
is his quote "We have a season off and we
have a year's hiatus, solely because I imagine
our storyline is up to the end of the books,"
he said.
"So, I get my year off now to do Rave of Thrones
and gallivant all over the world."
What does that mean, it means Hodor definitely
is not featured in season 5.
It’s the “we” part that is making everyone
think he meant everyone in Bran’s party,
or at least the ones still alive.
Under normal circumstances what you would
want to see from the person interviewing him
would be a hold on, let me get this straight.
You, Bran, Meera, The Child of the Forest,
The Three Eyed Raven.
They’re not doing any scenes with those
characters at all?
But that’s not the case, I’m not a huge
fan of celebrity interviews, because they
say a lot of things without saying anything
at all, just because HBO will sue them out
of existence if they spoil things.
I can only imagine the angry phone calls Kristian
Nairn is getting from their PR department
right now.
Whatever, here’s a couple of things his
comment could mean.
Let’s assume no Hodor, since he’s going
to be on tour.
Issac Hemstead Wright doesn’t have any other
projects he’s working on, so unless we see
him shooting something in the next couple
of months in a different part of the world.
He could still shoot some warging or flashback
scenes.
Quick spoiler warning for Bran’s character
in Book 5.
I’ll leave this spoiler tag up and you can
just skip till you don’t see it any more
if you don’t want to know anything...okay,
here we go.
So Bran spends time learning about the greensight
during Book 5 and learns that he can use the
weirwood trees to I guess you could call it
see back in time.
He can’t see forward, but he can see anything
in the field of vision of a weirwood for as
long as it’s been alive.
So he could peep on Ned Stark as a boy while
he was visiting the godswood in winterfell.
Or he could see the godswood in any of the
other castles of westeros as long as the trees
still exist there.
A lot of them have been cut down.
A lot of his time is spent learning how to
do this with the three eyed raven.
So why would they even cut him out?
It’s possible, if it’s true he’s not
in season 5, that the producers felt like
watching bran sit stationary under that tree
and do flashbacks all year, would slow down
the pace of the season.
Okay spoilers over.
Because it’s HBO it’s possible they just
want to focus on the biggest action scenes,
there have already been several spoilery scenes
filmed.
That I’ll talk about in other videos.
But they involve Cersei, Jaime, The Martells,
Tyrion, Ser Jorah and Daenerys.
I guess I just mentioned almost all the main
characters.
Lets just say there will be as many oh shit
moments as were in season 4.
I’ll talk about them all in future spoilery
videos if you guys want.
Remember, they cut Gendry out of Season 4
completely too because he didn’t have any
epic action scenes.
And they all but cut Bran out of Season 4.
So how would they bring him back into the
story if they do cut him out?
They’d either condense the flashback moments
to a single scene or cut it out entirely and
just reference it in past tense.
Picking up with Bran being a fully actualized
greenseer.
Since we haven’t gotten winds of winter
yet there are only theories and prophecies
about Bran’s role in the rest of the story.
Clearly he will be working with the Children
of the Forest.
In the great conflicts of the past the Children
have fought for the balance of nature.
For example, it’s implied they used the
hammer of waters to shatter the arm of Dorne
when the first men invaded westeros.
Then during the long night, the children were
the ones that discovered the white walkers
were vulnerable to obsidian, making a new
truce with the first men and pushing the forces
of the great other back.
Any time large magics get involved and the
climate changes, the children re-appear and
work to balance things.
For instance, I mentioned in my religions
and gods video.
If dragons overpopulated, the world would
start to overheat.
The Children would
start to help the white walkers balance the
climate and vis versa if it got too cold again.
I say all this because right now during current
events, melisandre supposedly has a vision
implying the three eyed raven serves the great
other.
The finale last year kind of contradicts that,
because the skeletons can’t enter his cave.
That just supports the idea that the children,
who all possess greensight.
Are a third neutral force between the great
other and r’hllor.
Bran will be working with them.
So whatever ends up happening, he could wind
up fighting against or with his old friends
and family.
The ones that are still alive.
Since the show probably won’t be doing any
of these things next season, they might just
bring him back when they’re ready to deal
with the white walker army attacking the wall.
I’ll probably do a winds of winter video
talking about what’s going on in the north
soon.
I have some thoughts about when they might
make their attack, so be sure to subscribe
to get that.
The giveaway is still running, I’ll announce
the winner in my next Q&A after my faith militant
video.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
Right now, click here to learn more about
my white walker prophecy theory and click
here to learn more about my top 5 prophecies
in general.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
high Fives!